"One Piece" is one of the best-selling
manga series of all time and arguably
one of the most popular pop culture
properties in the whole world. But
how did this pirate manga
become king of the stories?
Given the enormous success of both "One Piece"
and "Dragon Ball," it makes sense that Eiichiro
Oda was inspired in part by what Akira Toriyama
had done with his series. The folks at the One
Piece Podcast translated an interview between
Oda and "Naruto" writer Masashi Kishimoto,
in which the former called
Toriyama a "huge influence."
"I'd have to say that Toriyama-sensei
has been a huge influence. Of course,
there's "Dragon Ball," but I
really loved "Dr. Slump," as well."
Although the rules of each universe are different,
the core elements of "One Piece," and the
rogue cast of characters at its center have
a lot in common with the motley crew that Goku
assembles over the course of "Dragon Ball."
In a conversation with Toriyama, Oda
even acknowledged that he had fallen
in love with "Dragon Ball" the second
he stumbled across it. Oda also said
that there were specific things
about the art style in the series
that inspired him, including the way
that Toriyama drew muscles and hands.
Although we could forgive Eiichiro Oda for
deciding to rest on his laurels after creating one
of the most profitable stories in history, that's
not the path he chose. Instead, Oda continues to
work a very intense schedule, and does a lot of
the drawing for "One Piece" himself. This process
means that Oda is often working exceedingly long
days and suggests that he demands a lot of himself
in order to make sure that the stories in "One
Piece" are told the way he wants them to be.
Oda reportedly wakes up at 5 a.m., and continues
working on through 2 a.m. the next day,
and rarely takes a day off, even on weekends.
"One Piece" became an enormous success in part
because of Oda's attention to detail, and
it seems even now that it's world famous,
Oda still wants to make sure his story is told
with as much precision and care as possible.
Oda initially thought that he would be able to
end the story of "One Piece" after five years,
according to a translated quote found on an
Amino anime blog. Although Oda knows how the
series will end, he realized it would take
him longer to get there than he had initially
suspected. He also acknowledged that he liked
the story too much to wrap it up that quickly,
and ultimately decided to keep it going
much longer than originally planned.
In 2019, Oda said that he predicts "One Piece"
would end within the next five years, according
to Anime News Network. The series is on its way
toward a definitive conclusion, and at this point,
that ending is still the one that Oda envisioned
when he initially planned to end the series after
five years. Although the series will have run for
more than 25 years by the time it actually ends,
Oda is clearly committed to seeing his
vision for the manga's ending realized.
On top of the movies, video games, and the anime,
"One Piece" finally got a live-action
adaptation in 2023, courtesy of Netflix.
The live-action "One Piece" admittedly
caters to American fans of the series,
but it also works as part of Netflix's broader
push to reach a larger international audience.
"One Piece" is a global property, and with Oda
serving as an executive producer on the series,
fans around the world can be comfortable that
this new adaptation will continue to work as
yet another part of the franchise. Plus,
with a second season officially greenlit,
fans have more of the live-action
adventure to look forward to.
"That went pretty well… don't you think?"
Much like how "My Hero" was a pilot of sorts
for "My Hero Academia," "Romance Dawn" by
Eiichiro Oda was a prototype for the "One Piece"
story. The first version of "Romance Dawn" was a
50-page one-shot published in the "Shōnen Jump
1996 Summer Special" on August 4th. The second
version was only 45 pages long and released
in the 41st issue of "Weekly Shonen Jump" the
following month. Both versions share similar
elements that are present in the finalized
version of the manga while differing in many
ways. For example, Monkey D. Luffy is more
concerned about going on fun adventures than
becoming king of the pirates. The two female
leads from the respective versions of "Romance
Dawn" — Silk in the first version and Ann in the
second version — are clear prototypes of Nami. The
Devil Fruits are said to come from a mystical tree
in the second version of "Romance Dawn," while
their origin is still a mystery in "One Piece."
Red-Haired Shanks sacrifices his left arm to save
Luffy and gives Luffy his straw hat in the first
version of the story; in the second version, Luffy
is inspired by his pirate grandfather who shares
the same characteristics as Luffy's grandfather,
Monkey D. Garp, in "One Piece." "Romance Dawn" has
been adapted in various ways. The first version
was adapted as an anime special called "One Piece:
Romance Dawn Story." The second version
became Episode 907 of the TV anime series.
While Monkey D. Luffy went through minimal
changes through the various prototypes of
"One Piece," the remaining members of the Straw
Hat Pirates went through various changes in their
initial development before becoming the pirates
they are today. The characters of Silk and Ann
from "Romance Dawn" paved the way for Nami in the
finalized story. However, according to the fourth
databook, "One Piece Green: Secret Pieces,"
Nami originally had a giant battle-axe as her
signature weapon instead of a bō and was going to
be a cyborg. The adorable Tony Tony Chopper was
originally a more realistic reindeer who walked
on two legs and smoked. In an interview with
Shōnen Jump, Eiichiro Oda said the reason why
he changed Chopper's original appearance is it
blended too much with the other characters, so he
made Chopper more distinct, cute, and small. The
former pirate hunter Roronoa Zoro was envisioned
as the bodyguard for Buggy the Star Clown. The
chain-smoking cook Sanji was going to be named
Naruto, however, with the "Naruto" manga about to
start serialization, Oda wisely changed the name
to avoid any confusion between the two characters.
The fantasy world of "One Piece” might be a work
of fiction, but many of the series' outlandish
characters are inspired by real-life pirates from
the 17th century. Gol D. Roger, arguably the most
important character in "One Piece," shares
inspiration with two real-life pirates. The
first is the French pirate Olivier Levasseur who,
upon his hanging, tossed a cryptogram from the
scaffolding into the crowd and told them if they
could figure out the message his treasure would
be theirs. Levasseur's treasure was never found.
Similarly, Gol D. Roger tells pirates everywhere
to go look for his treasure, the One Piece, before
he's executed by the World Government. The second
source of inspiration for Gol D. Roger is Henry
Every, an English pirate who led possibly the
most profitable pirate raid of all time in 1695.
After capturing a treasure estimated at around $95
million in today's currency, Every became known
as "The Arch Pirate" for his tremendous wealth.
There are other examples of real-life pirate
references in "One Piece," such as the real
"Blackbeard," Edward Teach inspiring Marshall D.
Teach, leader of the Blackbeard Pirates. There's
also the Welsh pirate Bartholomew Roberts serving
as inspiration for Bartholomew Kuma , the legend
of Awilda for "Iron Mace" Alvida, and the Irish
pirate Anne Bonny for Captain Jewelry Bonney.
Easter eggs in anime are pretty common, and
"One Piece" is no exception to the rule. One
of the most prominent and commonly deployed
Easter eggs of Eiichiro Oda is Pandaman,
an anthropomorphic panda wrestler he drew for a
"Kinnikuman" character creation contest when he
was a teenager, as he explained in Vol. 7 of
the "One Piece" manga. As a joke character,
Pandaman has been featured in various
materials such as anime, manga, movies,
and video games. His lore even
unfolds in various backgrounds,
as his love interest Pandawoman, his
angry unpaid creditors the Tomato Gang,
and his great rival the Unforgivable Mask
have all made cameos in Oda projects.
Even though "One Piece" gets away with a lot
more than your average kids' cartoon in the U.S,
it still has a younger-skewing audience in
Japan. Therefore, the anime tends to water
down the manga's most graphic moments. Case in
point — characters who give the middle finger
in the manga do not do so in the anime. There
are various examples of characters flipping
the bird to others in the manga, so much
so that it became a running gag. The one
character most associated with this offensive
gesture is Trafalgar D. Water Law. When Law
meets Eustass Kid at the Human Auctioning House,
he gives him the middle finger. In the anime,
Law simply shoots Kid a smug grin. When
Donquixote Doflamingo defeats Law in the
"Dressrosa" arc of the manga, Law gives him the
middle finger in defiance. The anime version
dulls the edge of this rebellious moment by
having Law verbally mock Doflamingo instead.
There's no question that the works of
"Dragon Ball" and its ilk played a huge
role in the development of "One Piece," but
there's one obscure series that doesn't get
enough credit for inspiring Eiichiro Oda.
As he's stated in numerous interviews,
Oda became fascinated with the world of pirates
thanks to a little 1974 cartoon called "Vicky
the Viking." The show — which aired in Austria,
Germany, and Japan — follows a boy named Vicky
who is the son of Halvar, chief of the Viking
village of Flake. Despite being feeble, shy,
and terrified of wolves, Vicky manages
to get himself and his fellow Vikings out
of the toughest situations thanks to his
sharp imagination. Interestingly enough,
"One Piece" isn't the only anime inspired by
"Vicky the Viking." Makoto Yukimura, the writer
and illustrator of "Vinland Saga," has also cited
"Vicky the Viking" as a source of inspiration
and even drew some of the main characters
from the kids' show as cameos in his manga.
The "One Piece" TV anime series from Toei
Animation has been on the air since 1999.
During that time, the show has undergone
various changes in its animation style.
The recent adaptation of the "Wano Country" story
arc, for example, has experienced some significant
changes in the show's art style. Of course, change
isn't always a bad thing. Episode 1015 of "One
Piece" was praised as one of the most visually
stunning episodes in the series history. However,
not everyone is on board with the recent
stylistic changes to the show. A few fans
have harassed animator Henry Thurlow online,
believing him to be the cause of the show's
controversial use of power auras that recall
fight scenes from "Dragon Ball Z." To his credit,
Thurlow took it in stride and poked fun at the
thought of any single animator having so much
creative control over a mega-franchise
like "One Piece." There have also been
"One Piece" fans who have apologized for the
harassment Thurlow has received and offered
their support. On the One Piece Podcast, Thurlow
clarified the anime's use of auras, stating that
the decision of when to use it and by how much
is decided by the individual episode directors.
Thanks to the work of Funimation (now
known as Crunchyroll), the "One Piece"
anime series has experienced a resurgence in
popularity in North America. The series is
widely available in its original form, subbed
and dubbed, on various streaming platforms,
in digital stores, and home media releases.
Films like "One Piece: Stampede" have been
rolled out at North American theaters to
commercial success, with "One Piece Film:
Red" making its U.S. debut on November 4th of
2022. North American "One Piece" fans have it
good. That wasn't always the case, however, as
the defunct 4Kids Entertainment originally owned
the English rights to the "One Piece" anime and
subjected it to countless questionable changes.
Like most 4Kids dubs of its era, "One Piece"
was heavily censored to ridiculous degrees.
The 4Kids dubs were Americanized like crazy
and had most of its original music replaced
by an interchangeable track. Worst of all,
some episodes of "One Piece" were skipped or
merged into a singular episode. Needless to
say, fans were not happy with these changes.
The lasting legacy of the 4Kids dub of "One
Piece," however, is its American intro that
tells the story of the Straw Hat Pirates through
a reasonably corny rap song. Oddly enough, 4Kids
also produced an English cover of "We Are!," the
first "One Piece" anime opening song but decided
against using it. While hardly anyone mourns the
loss of 4Kids and their rights to "One Piece," the
fandom has embraced the 4Kids "One Piece" intro
music. After all, how many other classic anime
series can say they've got a rap theme song? And
who can hate a line like "Yo-ho-ho he took a bite
of Gum Gum!" Shawn Freshco Conrad, the man behind
the rap, explained how the theme song came to be.
He even updated the rap for the crew members
that don't get to appear in the 4Kids dub.
Who says Monkey D. Luffy doesn't have class? While
everyone's favorite straw hat-wearing hero hasn't
become king of the pirates just yet, he has set an
unexpected milestone in the real world. He became
the first anime character to grace the cover
of Shueisha's Men's Non-No fashion magazine
in 2009. This is an amazing feat considering
the publication's 24-year history at the time.
It also marked the first time Eiichiro Oda had
drawn a cover image for a non-manga magazine.
Various aspects of "One Piece" have
been influenced by historical figures
and real-life events. When designing the three
significant marine admirals from the series,
Eiichiro Oda turned to three late but great
Japanese actors as a source of inspiration
for their appearances. Kuzan is based on the
late Japanese actor Yūsaku Matsuda who starred
in films like "The Beast to Die," "Detective
Story," and "Black Rain." Matsuda's status as
an actor is so legendary that he also serves
as inspiration for Kenshiro from "Fist of
the North Star" and Spike Spiegel from "Cowboy
Bebop." Borsalino is based on the late Japanese
actor Kunie Tanaka who appeared in films like
"The Bad Sleep Well," "Sanjuro," and "Battles
Without Honor and Humanity." Finally, Sakazuki is
based on the late Japanese actor Bunta Sugawara.
As "One Piece" is hardly above
promoting products now and again,
a series of "One Piece" noodle commercials
reimagined the cast as modern-day high
schoolers. The advertising campaign
was called "Hungry Days" and it was
for the Japanese food company Nissin Foods
to advertise their lineup of instant noodles.
The modern-day designs of the Straw Hat
Pirates were drawn by Eisaku Kubonouchi
("Carole & Tuesday") and animated by Shaft
Animation Studio. In the ad campaign that ran from
May 2019 to February 2020, each commercial focused
on a crew member that evoked emotional moments
from the series related to that crew member, only
reinterpreted to fit the present-day high school
theme. The first commercial had Roronoa Zoro
swearing to get stronger after losing a kendo
match to Mihawk. The second has Nami being
overwhelmed by her high school studies and
evening work at the Arlong Pirates' restaurant.
The third commercial has Nefertari Vivi recalling
precious memories of her high school friends
(the Straw Hat crew) as she transfers to a
new school. The fourth is an all-out brawl
between the White Team (Whitebeard Pirates)
and Red Team (Marines) in an event involving
Monkey D. Luffy and his brother Portgas D. Ace.
One of the great things about the "One Piece"
series is the communication between fans and
series creator Eiichiro Oda. Through the
question-and-answer column in the manga,
Oda often answers fans' lingering questions
about the world of "One Piece," no matter
how ridiculous the questions may be. For
Volume 56 of the question-and-answer column,
there was one fan who had a more serious
question: "If One Piece was set in the real
world, which countries would the nine
Straw Hats come from?" Oda's response:
"Well. I'll just put what fits with the
character's image." Here's what Oda put down:
"Luffy: Brazil
Zoro: Japan
Nami: Sweden
Usopp: Africa
Sanji: France
Chopper: Canada
Robin: Russia
Franky: USA
Brook: Austria[.]"
Obviously, Africa is a continent
and not a country. Whether or not
Oda has an extremely limited
knowledge of global geography,
or simply didn't think hard enough about
this particular fan question is unknown.
Considering the love and admiration Eiichiro
Oda and Akira Toriyama have for one another,
it was inevitable that the two manga creators
would work together on a crossover involving
their popular series. And keeping
true to their wacky sense of humor,
the highly anticipated "One Piece x Dragon Ball"
crossover was anything but normal. "Cross Epoch,"
takes the cast of "One Piece" and "Dragon Ball"
and puts them in a far-out story where Mr. Satan
invites everyone to a little tea party after using
the Dragon Balls to wish to be king. In the end,
the "Dragon Ball" and "One Piece" crews all make
it on time and have fun. Some of the characters'
appearances and occupations are changed to better
mirror one another — Bulma becomes a thief to
match Nami, Piccolo masters sword fighting to
reflect Roronoa Zoro. This isn't the only time
"One Piece" and "Dragon Ball" have crossed over
with each other, as they often appear together in
various Shōnen Jump-related games like "Battle
Stadium D.O.N" or the ill-fated "Jump Force."
According to series creator Eiichiro Oda,
"One Piece" is entering its final story arc,
meaning the series' quarter-century journey will
soon come to an end. There's no telling where this
ship will sail for its final destination, but
there's one thing that everyone can be certain
of — before the series is complete, at least one
character in "One Piece" will wear an eye patch.
Confused? In the over one thousand chapters
of "One Piece," there has not been a single
pirate with an eye patch. The same is true for
the anime TV series and movies. Why? According
to Oda in the "One Piece 10th Treasures"
special collectors' book, he said he wanted
to avoid the stereotypical pirate look. Oda
is not against the idea of drawing a pirate
with an eye patch — he's just more interested
in the journey that gets them there. He wrote,
"I thought, if there's an image in
everyone's head about what a pirate is,
then I thought I would write [and] draw about the
process of the boy getting there. But
it's not like I dislike eye patches,
so in the final scenes of One Piece, there
is one pirate who appears with an eye patch."
Fans have speculated that the fabled
eye-patch-wearing pirate character
could be Monkey D. Luffy, as
the story of "One Piece" has
been his journey from a young
dreamer to king of the pirates.